toma como lo hizo desde el lujo que es
un suburbio a 35 km de parís y que es
ejemplo de los problemas que se viven en
este tipo de lugares el durante una hora
pues se dijo que esta estrategia pues no
busca crear amalgamas pero hay que
hablar de sin tapujos de ellis la más
radical en el país una estrategia que él
dividió en cinco puntos por una parte la
neutralidad de los servicios públicos un
mayor control de las asociaciones a ver
cómo se financian qué tipo de acciones
se realizan hablo muy importante de la
educación dijo que a partir de 2021 la
educación la instrucción será
obligatoria a partir de los 3 años y que
también pues las escuelas que no están
bajo contrato con el estado serán
sometidas a un arduo control para saber
qué tipo de programas están
implementando y también que quienes son
los pedagogos detrás de todo esto hijo
en una parte que el islám debe ir de la
mano de la república y por esto como
ustedes lo decía pues no podrán venir ya
y mums aquí a francia desde el
extranjero sino que son los imanes en
francia serán formados aquí mismo en el
país también pues habrá mayor control
también de saber quiénes están detrás de
las mezquitas como
y financian las acciones que están
realizando y para esto pues él también
quiere que haya una mayor inversión en
la educación superior todo esto pues
será presentado en un proyecto de ley a
comienzos de diciembre